have you ever wondered how much water
there is on earth I mean you can easily
google the answer it's 332 million cubic
miles but the problem is that this
number is simply too big to imagine
we've nicknamed the plane at the Blue
Marble because when viewed from space
the water is overwhelmingly visible
two-thirds of the surface is covered in
water but that doesn't begin to tell the
whole story so in this video I wanted to
see just how much water there really is
and whether or not we're going to run
out of it if you can remove every drop
of water on earth and form a sphere with
it how big would that sphere be they
might be thinking that it would probably
be larger than the moon because we have
a lot of water and the moon's not that
big I mean look at it it's literally
just sitting there on the earth yeah
good sit all right so what size are we
talking about here it would be it would
be this big which might be a little
smaller than you're expecting however
what you are seeing is all of the water
on earth all of the oceans lakes rivers
glaciers aquifers clouds and even the
water in all living things it all forms
a hydrosphere small enough to be a moon
of our Moon but how is that the case how
is it possible for that tiny little
sphere to cover so much of our planet in
water well the answer is that the earth
is relatively flat
no no I mean that it's smooth
not flat you see Earth may have very
deep trenches and giant mountains but
compared to the width of the entire
planet the difference between them is
basically nothing you may have heard
that if you were to shrink the earth
down to the size of a billiards ball
that it would actually be smoother and
that billiard ball in truth however
that's a little bit of a misconception
because the earth would actually feel
closer to 320 grit sandpaper but let's
be real that's still pretty dang smooth
plus a little bit of water goes a pretty
long way as anyone who's ever spilled a
glass of water certainly knows even a
small volume of water can cover a really
large area and that's exactly what
happened here on earth if earth was the
size of an apple the oceans would be
seven times thinner than the skin of
that Apple now don't get me wrong that
is still a lot of water obviously I mean
yeah it's 860 miles wide but that means
it's also 860 miles tall that is three
times further out into space than where
the International Space Station orbits
the earth well what is all of that how
much of it is freshwater versus salty
ocean not much only two-and-a-half
percent of all water is fresh however if
here to gather only the fresh water it
would still form a sphere 250 miles wide
that's twice the width of Florida so uh
take that Florida I guess here's the
thing though yeah it's fresh water but
that doesn't mean it's drinkable liquid
fresh water most of that is ice
you see 61 percent of all freshwater is
actually frozen in the Antarctic ice
sheet which is a massive plate of ice
the size of a freaking continent if you
were to separate all of the ice from the
freshwater sphere it would look like
this that's a that's a pretty hefty
snowball so where's the rest of the
freshwater well most of it is actually
underground and I'll get back to that in
a moment obviously we have lakes rivers
clouds Oh permafrost which is just
frozen dirt we actually have three times
the amount of permafrost than we do in
all of the lakes combined
freakin frozen dirt FMD in fact all of
the world's fresh water supply lakes and
rivers only account for 0.3 percent of
it that small little ball meets most of
the freshwater needs of humanity and all
of life for that matter it is
35 miles wide and at this scale you can
now begin to see individual cities but
that sphere also contains all of the
world's freshwater rivers as well and
we're talking you know the Mississippi
the Nile the Yangtze the Amazon they
only add up to 2% of all surface
freshwater and would form a sphere of
mere 10 miles wide to compare there is
six times that amount of water in the
air around us and some of that is in the
clouds sure but most of it is actually
in the water vapour that you can't even
see it's invisible
now get this though you and I we're
mostly made out of water but that goes
for every single animal plant bug even
bacteria if you can remove the water
composition from every living thing it'd
be half the volume of even the rivers
okay now remember when I mentioned that
most of the water is underground well if
you're able to extract all of that it
would form a sphere 160 miles wide
however we can only really use about six
percent of that water due to a number of
different reasons like accessibility and
renewability issues with the source the
average American for instance uses about
90 gallons of water per day which is 18
of these classic-looking water jugs and
of course that's divided between things
like flushing toilets bathing cooking
washing etc it all adds up however where
we really use our water is indirectly by
eating it we don't directly see it so
food for example uses a lot of water to
produce and beef in particular a single
pound of beef requires 1,800 gallons of
water which is 360 of these same water
jugs and I realize that might be hard to
believe because it doesn't seem
physically possible but don't forget
that cows they eat a lot of corn and all
that corn requires a lot of water to
grow it's kind of seeming like there's
not really that much water to go around
and yet humanity uses a lot of water so
are we going to run out or not and the
short answer is no but there's not an
actual simple answer to this question it
is estimated that humanity uses 4
trillion cubic meters of water per year
and that comes out to a sphere that's
about 12 miles wide every year see the
real problem here is water scarcity not
whether or not we're gonna run out of it
there's a lot of water left the original
point of this video was just to kind of
show how much water there is on earth I
thought I'd be some sweet visuals I
didn't even plan this part of the video
I haven't written anything for
I'm just kind of talking now so if
you're wondering what kind of things you
can do to help solve this problem well
the first step is simply to be mindful
of your water usage I'm not asking you
to become vegan I'm not vegan I love
beef burgers however that being said
I've kind of fallen in love with the
beyond burger its plant-based and uses
99 percent less water than its beef
counterpart and honestly it's really
hard to tell the difference the world
from Carl's jr. is pretty solid
this isn't sponsored I'm just saying so
yeah I'm just simply asking you to be
more mindful of this as a problem maybe
share this video your friends yeah I'm
just glad you watched it I'm tired
this video comes out tomorrow and we're
doing a merchandise push check this out
over a quarter digital that storm we put
this really cool hoodie up for sale and
it is so comfortable it sold out in the
first day we decided to bring you back
for a limited run place your orders now
because you have until the end of
February to get this limited-edition
item now we are only going to make as
many of these as we sell don't miss out
I mean come on these videos are not the
sort of thing you can just make every
single day so thanks for watching and
stay tuned in the next video where I
compare the size of buildings to that of
Tom